Destiny you mentioned the Loverboy
method do you think that the Loverboy
method is actually sex trafficking and
why
um I don't have thoughts on it or it's
not like my goal is to Define like what
is sex trafficking I just go by what the
laws are and usually the questions are
is he guilty of the crime of sex
trafficking and the lover boy method is
defined as sex trafficking I believe in
most countries because at least in
Romania and I think in most countries if
you are able to get a girl to do sex
work using a coercive or fraudulent
method meaning you're Miss uh you're
misleading them as to what your
relationship is then that would
constitute sex trafficking if you
exploit them afterwards for sex work